three two one booster's indignation
and liftoff of Artemis one
50 years after the last Apollo astronaut
left footprints on the moon NASA is on
its way back we rise together back to
the moon and Beyond
the most powerful rocket ever built
finally lifted off from Kennedy Space
Center in Florida after weeks of delays
a mesmerizing start for a 1.3 million
mile Test Flight of the Orion spacecraft
this time there's no crew but if all
goes well humans will be on board in
just two years time I'm telling you
we've never seen such a
a tale of flame
there were a bunch there that would like
to be on that rocket we're going back to
the Moon not just for the sake of going
to the Moon
but to learn to live to prepare to send
humans all the way to Mars
Orion's Journey To The Moon will take
around a week it will orbit several
times coming as close as 60 miles to the
surface and as far away as 40 000
further into deep space than any other
craft built to take humans roughly two
weeks later Orion will head home
barreling into the atmosphere at almost
25
000 miles an hour and splashing down off
the coast of California on December the
11th
NASA hopes this journey will one day be
routine ferrying astronauts to a lunar
base camp a few hours into the flight
came the first images of Earth slowly
receding into the black curtain of space
so much to learn from the Moon in terms
of science
um it is a unique record of the solar
system so it tells us about how the
Earth evolved how it will evolve in the
future and by sending humans there to to
collect rocks to do the geology we will
find exciting things this is your moment
Artemis is a very different lunar
program to Apollo the first female
launch director and on a future Mission
the first woman and first person of
color to land on the moon it's not just
the technology that has changed over the
last 50 years Thomas More Sky News